(dramatic music)
- [Josephine] In 1947, the first
H&M store opened in Sweden.
And by 2019, there were over
5,000 H&Ms around the world,
about 3000 more than its competitor Zara.
- [Interviewer] How long have you waiting
this morning in the queue?
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Josephine] It collaborated
with fashion giants
like Versace, Balmain, and Karl Lagerfeld.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] The world has changed.
What we do today will define our tomorrow.
- [Josephine] But recently,
H&M has struggled.
The company's net income
dropped during the pandemic.
And 2022 was one of the
store's least profitable years
in over two decades.
That same year H&M laid
off 1500 employees.
So what went wrong?
(dramatic music)
- This morning major American
companies pulling business
out of Russia, Disney, Warner
Brothers, ExxonMobil, Ford.
- [Josephine] Russia was
H&Ms sixth largest market.
But after Russia invaded Ukraine,
H&M decided to close all
of its stores in Russia
and stop online sales to the country.
The company cited operational challenges
and an unpredictable future.
- They, of course, faced
this unprecedented situation,
like a lot of brands last
year with Russia's invasion
of Ukraine, that forced them
to close a lot of stores
in what was one of their bigger markets,
about 5% of their global sales.
So H&M would argue that without that hit
they would've had a
fairly decent last year.
- [Helena] So our decision to
wind down the business there
has had a significant negative
impact on our results.
- [Josephine] The war also
helped fuel inflation,
increasing raw material,
and logistical costs.
Besides pulling out of Russia,
H&M has had longstanding
problems in China,
another important market.
(speaking in foreign language)
Consumers in China boycotted
the company in 2021
after H&M raised concerns
about alleged forced labor
and discrimination
against ethnic minorities
in China's cotton production.
Chinese consumers and online
retail apps like Tmall,
Pinduoduo, and JD boycotted H&M.
Map apps like Baidu also removed
H&M from their platforms.
- They've never really
recovered from that issue.
They're still trying to find a way back
into the China market.
- [Josephine] H&M also faced
a setback when Covid lockdowns
in China led to store
closures in the country.
- First, I got this hoodie.
I am actually obsessed with this.
- One big factor they face
is their brand position.
They're are a fast fashion brand
so all about being relatively cheap.
But in recent years, they've
faced this new competition
from online fast fashion
players, like SHEIN,
who are even cheaper, even
quicker to get new designs
onto the market.
- [Josephine] SHEIN has
come onto the market
as one of H&Ms fast fashion competitors.
And unlike H&M, SHEIN is
an online only retailer.
- They don't have physical
stores, that's their model.
- [Josephine] On the other hand,
H&M relies heavily on in-store sales.
Only about 30% of its
sales come from online.
- So H&M faces this predicament
that on the low side,
they're being out flanked
by SHEIN and online players.
But do you try and trade up?
Because if you do, then you are coming
into direct competition
with a brand like Zara,
which in the mind of a lot of consumers
is a slightly higher end brand.
They've already closed something like 12%
of their global stores.
And analysts generally think
that's the right way to go.
That you close the underperforming stores,
invest in the best stores
because most consumers
still like to shop in physical stores,
but then also try and build
up the digital side as well.
- [Josephine] But can
H&M get customers excited
about the brand again?
- Fashion is a tricky business, of course,
'cause it relies a lot on
this sort of intangible idea
of brand heat and whether your brand
resonates with consumers.
And H&M seems to have lost a
little bit of that resonance
with a lot of consumers.
Can they get consumers excited again
about H&M clothes at the
price point they're at?
And at the moment they, maybe
they're having some success,
but I think they'd like to see a lot more
to really get young consumers
especially back on board.
(dramatic music)